now let's get a European perspective on
a Trump Clinton face off Roderick
Roderick Keys Vetter it's an mp4
Chancellor Merkel's CDU party it's also
a member of the Foreign Affairs
Committee of the German Bundestag
welcome to DW so it looks likely then
that Hillary Clinton will face Donald
Trump on the presidential ballot which
of them would offer greater continuity
in relations with the EU and of course
with Germany well first of all it's up
to the American population to find a
solution but i think that the candidate
clinton is much more moderate and we
need the transatlantic cohesion and
therefore in europe you find a lot of
supporters for Hillary Clinton why is
moderation a good thing well what we
need in the simultaneous of crises is a
strong link amongst the United States of
America and Europe and we need trust
confidence building we need really a
closer cooperation because between our
two continents there is a need of burden
sharing and we have received a lot of
security for decades from the United
States of America and in the future the
European Union needs to take over more
responsibility in her close vicinity
like northern Africa like near Middle
East but this is only possible if Europe
is backboned by strong United States and
if the United States know that somebody
is taking up common interests in our
region and therefore we need these close
links so you talked about a lack of
trust there is that it did if there was
a trump presidency do you think there
would be a lack of trust that the
Europeans would distrust president Trump
or that president Trump would distrust
Europeans I think the election campaign
shows that people in the united states
do not trust in the current
establishment and on the other side
Trump has to gain trust of the political
leaders and the parliamentarians and the
economy on the European side and so he
is unknown in this context
he is very able to to show polarization
he is very able to mobilize people but
we have not yet seen his diplomatic
skills and so we have to wait for that
and on the other side we need a lot of
diplomatic skills we need to balance the
different challenges we have and this is
only possible with a close transatlantic
link and I do not see in the election
campaign that Donald Trump is looking
for a mutual trust he is just showing
that it is possible for one human being
having a lot of money available having a
lot of good relations to to certain
donators he is showing that he can
change a political establishment which
was well known for decades of stability
and therefore we really need to learn a
little bit more and I personally I am
not so trustful that Donald Trump is
willing to build up trust amongst our
two continents on the other side it's up
to the American population and I hope
that this population is wise enough to
go at the election day to the voting
cells and are trying to help well we'll
see what happens good talk and you thank
you so much a rudder keys better thank
you